ALEX IN NEW YORK CITY.
WE BEGIN WITH GRIF JENKINS IN
WASHINGTON.
>> AMERICANS ARE BRACING FOR A
LOCK DOWN OR A NATIONWIDE
SHUTDOWN FOR THE NEXT FEW
MONTHS.
THE CDC ISSUED THESE NEW
GUIDELINES CALLING FOR AN 8 WEEK
BAN OF GATHERINGS OF 50 OR MORE
PEOPLE.
IT’S FOR ANYONE ORGANIZING
SPORTS EVENTS OR WEDDINGINGS.
CITIES WILL RESTRICT BARS AND
RESTAURANTS AND NIGHT CLUBS.
THE MAYOR OF LOS ANGELES ALSO
CLOSING MOTIVE THEATRES AND
BOWLING ALRYLEYS AND GYMS FOR A
MONTH.
THE SITUATION HAS THE POTENTIAL
TO BE ITALY.
>> WE ARE AT A CRITICAL POINT.
WE ARE WHERE ITALY WAS 2 WEEKS
AGO IN TERMS OF NUMBERS.
WE HAVE A CHOICE TO MAKE:
DO WE WANT TO GO THE DIRECTION
OF SOUTH KOREA AND LOWER
MOREITALITY RATES ARE BE ITALY.
>> THE PRESIDENT PLEADED WITH
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WE ARE NOT
RUNNING OUT OF FOOD AND TO STOP
EMPTYING THE SHELVES AT STORES.
THIS COMES AS THE PRESIDENT’S
TASK FORCE TOLD US WE SHOULD
EXPECT A NUMBER OF CASES TO RISE
AS TESTING SPEEDS UP THIS WEEK.
WE MAY GET ACTION BECAUSE THE
SENATE IS BACK IN SESSION.
THEY WILL PICK UP WHERE THE
HOUSE BILL THAT JUST PASSED.
MITCH MCCONNELL SAID THERE MAY
BE MORE BILLS NEEDED TO ADDRESS